[Music]
on today's show we talk about boundaries
in marriage from in-laws to brothers
we talk with a mom whose teen daughter
is facing a mental illness diagnosis
and what she can do next stay tuned
[Applause]
hey what's up what's up this is the dr
john dolone show
i'm john i think so highly of myself i
named a show after my i didn't actually
name the show but hey i'm glad you're
here thanks for hanging out we're going
to talk about relationships and your
life and your mental health
pretty much anything that's going on in
the world around you
to show for you about you by you give me
a call
at 1-844-693-3291 that's
of 1-844-693-3291 before we get rolling
today the first one is james
i got a couple of um dms they call them
that's what the kids say somebody
slid into my dms is that i don't even
know if i probably just said something
bad don't cancel me
um but they wanted to know where this
music is like
hey what song is this i just heard it
before and i was thinking i don't think
you've heard it
isn't it like in the intro yeah you
built that right no i didn't build it
it's uh it's like a licensed
music library that we have so it's not
really like commercial music you could
find on spotify
necessarily but one it was two songs and
you stitched them together
no no i edited it a little bit to make
it a quicker intro but it's not
i didn't like do anything besides that
okay but i'm glad that you think so
highly of me i thought you
just were at home just had your you know
your headphones on and you were just
getting after it nope
nope just bought it off the internet
it's 25.95
okay for both of you today at lunch i
was sitting with
will and some other folks and i was like
hey guys i gotta run go potty real quick
because i got little kids and they
looked at me and i was like hey
do you all ever do that say i gotta go
tt
first of all tt no i know i know that
was that's a foul
but before the show you told me hey i'll
be right in there i gotta go pee pee
and i about threw up in my mouth well it
wasn't because of that
i just i'm just used to it i got a
little kid
you too kelly no no
because i'm self-respecting adult i
don't say tt
but i do you know i still ask my 15 year
old if he has to go potty
see and he looks at me and goes mom see
so
it's part of the burn it is part of the
vernacular but don't use
all right moratorium i'll just say i'll
stick with potty
i'll just say bathroom how about that
yeah i'm gonna tell my little daughter
hey you going to the bathroom i don't
know why it makes me think of
old days at the astrodome doing the old
astros games back i don't know it just
sounds weird
all right so we're glad you're here
let's go to uh rachel
on the phones in uh where she at
greensboro north carolina rachel what's
going on how can i help
hi dr delany how are you i am just
i'm doing great i'm doing good great
so um my fiance and i are
planning our wedding for september and
um among the conversations that we were
having
was that he anticipates um being a
caregiver and caregiver for him two of
his brothers
with mental disabilities and
so i just wanted some advice on how to
navigate that
i hear in your voice that you are not
expecting that and
you were not looking forward to this
i i kind of did but as the wedding
starts approaching it just becomes more
of a reality
and it kind of just um
solidifies um i know that to a certain
extent what is this oh
what does it solidify are you is this a
deal breaker for you
no no no absolutely not it's just
essentially trying to figure out how
much of
a how much of a like a
mental and emotional burden it would be
on our relationship and our future
so he's just trying to process that and
kind of figuring out the best way
to deal with all of it without
um without offending people on the
process
without like stepping on anybody's toes
in the process
and things like that so so it's gonna be
a big strain
and it's gonna be hard and it's still
probably gonna be the right thing
those aren't all mutually exclusive and
having a good marriage is hard it's
gritty and annoying and frustrating
and lots of tears and then you get up
and you do it again and
as the great therapist terence real says
one person's always jumping off the deep
end and it's the other person's job
they're not jumping after them right
somebody's got to stay stable that's
part of it um
there's something deeper here what do
you mean you don't want to step on
people's toes and make people frustrated
what do you what do you mean by that
well
obviously like the the mental
disabilities for
both of us brothers have been going on
for a long time
and they are both very
functional they can they're able to hold
jobs to a certain extent
but also there's also
the part where i know that like
he wants to he anticipates taking care
of
them emotionally and possibly
financially in the future
but it's also the part where he doesn't
wanna
um he knows it's gonna be his
responsibility but he doesn't wanna i
guess
overstep his boundaries as far as with
his parents
okay but he feels like he knows it
because he was sharing with me that
early on
um i guess something happened when he
was still very young
in his teenage years where he realized
that
oh this is going to be on me in the
future does he have any brothers and
sisters
i'm sorry does he have any brothers or
sisters
uh yes he has one more brother
and that dude's m.i.a not gonna help
um yeah he will we just don't know how
the situation is going to be
is your husband is he being a martyr
he's the oldest
maybe i mean is it like i'm gonna have
to do all this stuff and i'm gonna
is that is it that too no no i think
that he just feels the responsibility
being the oldest okay
that he he's gonna need to take to step
up and take care of him
okay so this is a
potential issue way down the road
and it sounds like there's a lot of
what-ifs a lot of future
what ifs that we're allowing to poison
our right now okay and
so all of this is solved with a really
straightforward
not even hard but a straightforward hey
we're all sitting down having a
conversation
with his parents with your his brother
and him
and my brother and i have done this my
sister and i have done this
my dad and my mom have had this
conversation um
now we don't have special needs kids in
the house but we do have
various situations in our family here's
how this is gonna happen if i pass away
here's how this is gonna and we just
walked through that together
um and so if i'm your brother
i mean i'm sorry if i'm your fiance i
just made that weird if i'm your fiance
um i would call my parents
and say hey let's i want to talk through
what's the what's the plan i need to
know
if there is a um a special needs trust
which should have been set up for those
boys already
um what is what is y'all's plan as y'all
age
are they gonna continue to live just get
it all out in the open there's nothing
to be weirded about here there's nothing
to be
ashamed of about here this is just
something that you got to deal with head
on
and then once you know and begin to make
a plan then you begin to make a plan
a plan is about as useful as when the
actual situation shows up
right as mike tyson says everyone's got
a plan until you get hit in the mouth
and then things change so you have a
plan and you hold it really loosely you
be graceful with one another
you on the other hand need to ask
yourself
are you going to be married to this guy
with potentially two of his brothers
moving into your home
i hear something in your voice that says
that you're not comfortable with this
you feel weird about this you're
stressed about this
and um you need to know now going in the
kind of guy you're marrying is a guy
that says
i'm going to take care of my family
and i agree with that and i i
anticipated that and i'm
completely okay with it it's just
i feel like between the two of us we can
handle it
but then when there is everybody else's
input
and what we you know how we decide to
help and things like that
is when things get more complicated yeah
and they don't get a vote
they don't it doesn't matter what they
say right now if they're on
a part of the special needs trust if
they have holes over the money if
they're the executor of the will then
yeah they're going to have a choice
i don't think there is no such a thing
to begin with yeah you can get one with
enough
planning they need to get one of those
yesterday yesterday they need to get one
of those
um that's a that is an asap
do not pass go get that thing done okay
you want to make sure your kids are
taken care of especially with special
needs after you're gone
um i cannot emphasize how important it
is to have a will
have a will have a will have a will if
you've got children with special needs
have a special needs trust
do it yesterday um
these are not hard conversations and i
don't mean to make make a light of this
rachel
these are just direct let's just have
this thing and let's all get on the same
page here
um i would be happy
to marry somebody who's cares about his
family and is thinking down the road
what y'all both need to do is don't cash
out your present day happiness your
present day excitement over about
something that may or may not happen
years down the road
okay um life is too short things are too
bananas you need to enjoy what you have
today and you need to be excited about
the fact that you're about to get
married
if for some reason do you say i'm out of
this thing
i just don't want to have a future where
i've got two other
grown men living at my house man have
the dignity to let him know now and then
walk away with your head up
head held high if that's what you choose
um
don't go into this marriage
knowing where your your fiance's heart
is knowing the situation of his brothers
and then slowly drag the whole machine
underwater
and drown everybody in the process there
are going to be a lot of people with a
lot of opinions on this
but if your brothers i mean if your
fiance is the one pwning up the money
pony up the house
taking care of them nobody else gets a
vote zero none
just y'all two y'all get to craft this
what this looks like y'all two get to
decide
who gets a vote so here's what i want
you to do as a as a premarital exercise
i want you guys to get a real box
like a shoe box a little fancy bot i
don't care what it is the real thing
put it on your kitchen table and i want
you
to write out four or five people on
planet earth
who get a vote into your marriage that
could be another couple that you all
know that could be a marriage counselor
that could be
close friends that you each have that
could be whoever you want
and put it in there and i want you to
close that box and let it sit for a day
then i want you all to circle back and i
want you to open it up each of you
together and explain to the other person
why you're doing what you're doing
why are you giving this person a say
into our marriage into our relationship
what are we talking about here
why are we doing this and then here's
the thing once y'all agree on who goes
in that box
nobody else gets a vote his mom can call
you and say i just thought
that he would have married somebody who
i know you don't get a vote
right you're gonna be respectful of
course but you don't get any input
well we just expected at christmas y'all
we're gonna well i appreciate that so
much but we're not gonna do that we're
going to arkansas we're going to the
moon we're going to wherever right
you all get to decide that as a couple
but have those conversations up front
have them right now and the names in
that box will evolve and shift and
change over time
but it's the intentionality exercise of
who are we letting speak into this house
it's not in-laws it's not my parents
it's not the vet
it's not the fill in the blank right
whoever else it's gonna be
right um and then just sit down with his
parents and have a honest direct
straightforward conversation
i'm about to get married i'm about to
start creating my own legacy my own
household
and i have the expectation i'm gonna be
taking care of my two brothers down the
road
what is y'all's plan what does y'all's
will look like what is the plan moving
forward for when we're going to
transition this
and then have that direct conversation
put everybody on notice that this is how
this is going to be
and they go from there i appreciate that
call rachel i know that sounds complex
and hard and scary especially when i'm
even married yet
but there's not a way to go into that
other than directly
and not being an idiot and a jerk and i
know y'all wouldn't do that but going
there with dignity and respect
and a on the on the table what are we
gonna do about our
my brothers all right thanks for social
call let's go to kyle
in fort smith arkansas what's up kyle
how we doing
i'm doing good doctor john when my wife
turned 18
her mother opened up credit cards in my
wife's name without her no
how much about fifteen thousand dollars
she didn't pay a penny on it has she no
oh jeez
and so we've been uh we found out
shortly before we got married which has
been about four years ago
now and all because i answered a phone
call that my wife didn't
know so i answered it turned out she was
behind on the payments so we figured it
all out
wow and her dad her dad doesn't know
and the reason is that she couldn't get
a credit card because
uh they'd had a credit card bankruptcy
prior
years so she stole from her child
exactly and this she stole from her
adult child which makes this a whole
different ball game right
exactly and i want paid back okay
and so we uh we've been working on it
trying to think of
different ways to do it and uh you know
being that her dad doesn't know
i guess he didn't take the bankruptcy
very well because the mother has always
handled money
so my wife's very concerned that him
finding out about this
will be you know more than he can handle
and with some with some mental issues
and so
we're so here's the deal kyle i'm gonna
save your heart here okay let's hear it
you're not getting a penny back
just just go ahead it's not gonna happen
um
the choices you you guys have to make
are
filing a dispute with the credit bureau
right
saying that these were stolen these
charges are fraudulent i never have
y'all done that
no no it's been too many years um i
would dispute it
at least have a write a letter in
writing
the second thing you'll need to decide
is are you going to
call the police on your on your
mother-in-law and say she robbed me
do you need to go get another cr does
your wife need to go get another social
security number
because if it happened once it could
happen again and once she's
put fraudulent stuff put a police report
out there that somebody stole my thing
and took out credit cards somebody told
my social security numbers took out
credit cards
then the next thing is i need to get a
new social security number so that mom
can't steal from me anymore
and then y'all gotta go move on about
your day the chances of you getting this
back are
zero the chances of y'all end up going
to war with your in-laws is a hundred
percent
and i just i don't know the value and
the benefit of that
you okay okay what do you think about
that
well you see hey you're like me and i
guarantee you've already spent that
money
yeah yeah yeah it's i mean it's been
there eating at me you know i've been
paying
you know my wife was paying for it
originally she said well i'm just going
to keep my job pay it well we had a
little boy he's home
so she's home with him now and that's
where i want her to be that's why i love
that
and so now i'm eating that 420
a month and we haven't even been hardly
paying anything down on it we
you know reconsolidated it and made it
to where we can
you know manage no you consolidated it
with other loans
yeah we it well with all because the
three loans together
and we just consolidated those three
okay fifteen thousand
that may make it more a lot of money
yeah and i think
i the man i know her dad would not
it i don't see anything ending bad i
think he's going to be mad about it yeah
but i think he'd find a way to come up
with the money they have assets to sell
they're both retired
okay so who's telling you not to call
him
my wife she is scared to death she cries
about it it just and you know 20 20 was
hard for everybody and so we got a
little bit behind so guess what i could
i quit paying first
those credit cards i hate here's the
thing though it's
it's in your heart it's a
it's an existential deal but for the
banks if they don't care
you got to keep paying that bill right
and we and we got
caught back up and everything but i i
did pretty well sold a project
her mother knew that we sold the project
well the va the credit cards had called
her mother in that time because they
keep all the phone numbers
and so they called her well then she
called us why aren't you paying the
credit cards
well when she found out we we started
paying on
or that we sold a big project made some
good money she
told my wife when are you going to pay
off the debt and i just
i've lost my mind over that that's
what's the reason for this call right
now hey that's fair
that's i i'd be upset and fired up too
um but what you're doing is you are
allowing an input
but you're stuck with the output right
right so cut your mother-in-law off
you're done you don't get a vote in my
life
i'm not you're a thief and now you're
dishonest
and um you stole from your child and i'm
we're done with that if someone stole
from
their 19 year old or 18 year old and it
was a it was a moment of weakness things
got bananas around the house we were
gonna lose something
and they circled back three or four five
years later and said i screwed up in a
major way i'm embarrassed and i'm
ashamed and i'm gonna make it right
that's one thing but then when someone's
calling saying hey you guys need to get
these creditors off my
off my back um i mean
no you that's your true colors that's
who you are you know what god be with
you go have fun with your life i'm
you're you're not having any influence
in my life you're not gonna see my kid
you're not going to poison my wife
anymore we're going to create our own
legacy and we're going to move on
from somebody who's not a thief and
somebody who's not dishonest
that's it and i know that that's hard
because your wife's not going to be on
board with that is that right
that's right okay now have you sat down
with your wife
and said i need to be vulnerable here
and there's a hundred percent chance
you've not done this i'm setting you up
okay so just know we're on the same team
here
um i'm being vulnerable here i committed
my life to loving you
i committed my life to protecting you i
committed my life to being vulnerable
with you
and your your mom stole from her child
your mom has continued to beat us up
over her debt
that we're having to pay off in a season
we don't have the money to be paying it
off
and you have a dream of staying home
with our son
i've got a dream of giving the woman of
my life whatever she wants however i can
love and support her
and every time your mom calls i feel
like she's
hurting her family again and again and
again and
i'm asking for us to take a season off
from
having your mom in our life and
letting your wife truly hear your heart
on this deal because my guess is it only
comes up when you get one of these calls
when you write that 400
check and it comes out as an explosion
which then comes out as you verse her
mom
and nobody wins in that exchange exactly
if it comes out you versus her mom she
has to defend her mom just because
she's got to defend you just because and
sh the person who loses there is your
wife
if you come at her as not me versus mom
but me plus you that's a whole different
equation
right but uh i mean what about her dad
in the end should i burn the whole place
down and
let everybody know you know there's a
fault in the wiring just by telling them
if you want to lose your marriage over
go ahead man
you think think so i don't want to do
that your wife has said please don't do
that
right and do you want to be right or do
you want to be in love and married
no i want to be in love and married okay
then man this is a uh
this is a painful painful hard
fifteen thousand dollar pill to swallow
sucks
hate it well you know what i mean i can
deal with it
yeah but but it is it happened and then
yeah let's let's
man let's work triple and quadruple and
get this thing knocked out it may
be that your your wife's dream of
staying at home
is gonna have to be put on hold for six
to nine months so she can crank that out
yeah and that you can go home and hold
that baby while she does uber eats or
something like that and
cranks that thing out and pays that
sucker off
yeah absolutely and then everybody can
be back on the same page but here's the
thing
all of this conversation starts from two
places number one we're drawing a
boundary no more mom
no more mother-in-law in our life for a
season at least
number two um this is not
us versus them this is me plus you
this is me connecting with my wife with
someone i love and i want to be engaged
with here and
ever it's not your mother anymore it's
just this lady that keeps hurting her
family
and i'm asking that she'd not be around
her kid i don't want him getting the
stuff
i'm asking that she not be around us
right now this is hard
and i want to focus on you guys not the
other way around um
listen if i'm you i'm in the exact
same place kyle i want that money back
i'd want to call everybody i'd go knock
on and and
talk to to my my my father-in-law
face-to-face hey listen here man i'd do
it
um i'd want to do it but if my wife said
hey please don't then i'm going to honor
that
because she knows more about that
situation than i do and um
and then you got to just swallow it and
move on with your day
life's too short man um and then i would
strongly strongly recommend that your
wife get a new social security number
your your mom is not somebody to be
trusted with that kind of information
all right i want to take a quick break
and answer one of the most common
questions i get
deloney i can't find a counselor in my
area or i can't afford one
listen help is here i've partnered with
better help
for customized online therapy for you
video therapy phone therapy or you can
even
text with a licensed therapist in your
area or somewhere across the country
to get the help that you need when you
need it
go to betterhelp.com deloney for 10
off your first month listen online
therapy is
less expensive than in-person therapy
i've taken away
all of your excuses now you have to
recognize you're worth being well
go see a counselor online with
betterhelp.com
today alright so i got this email from
jenny
jenny wrote in she says how do you feel
when
couples say they never fight is that
healthy
so a couple of things here when it comes
to mine one
if you define fighting as yelling
slamming stuff throwing no
i think that's all ridiculous dumb
behavior it's not productive at all and
so
if somebody says we don't fight meaning
we don't yell and scream and throw crap
then yeah i believe that because i don't
do that at my house
but if it's um if they're defining
fighting as disagreements
as anger and frustration
man me and my wife don't yell or slam or
throw things but
i'll tell you about me i won't tell you
about my wife i weaponize silence
right i am the master at withdrawing
um and usually so i don't say something
stupid so i don't do something dumb i
want to control but i
end up controlling by withdrawing and
here's the thing it's fighting
it leaves bruises on somebody's soul it
leaves bruises on somebody's
um heart and mind it doesn't leave
bruises on their body right it go wreck
somebody's heart it doesn't wreck the
furniture right
so i think it comes down to how you
gonna define fighting
i don't yell i hate yelling um it's
actually traumatic
right it's uh it's a trauma for kids
especially and it
solves nothing unless somebody's walking
into the street and about to be hit by a
car
yelling is dumb don't do it but that
doesn't mean
my wife don't fight we disagree often
passionately but we respect each other
and we've had to work hard on fighting
fair
right hard on fighting fear fighting not
to fight
but to get towards a resolution that
improves everybody's lives
so here's the way i look at fighting
fighting is often a result
of a clogged pressure valve right if
you're not talking if you're not
communicating if you don't have open
lines of
communication back and forth if you're
not able to say dude i had a super weird
dream last night
or i slept like crap last night or i
miss you or
last night i came in for a kiss and you
turned your head and i acted weird and
then i got weird and you got weird and
then i just let
if you don't have those little
conversations over time then that
pressure valve builds up and builds up
right
so the first and most important thing is
have regular conversations what are you
reading what are you watching
shows you like shows you don't like what
are your disagreements on this when are
we going to buy this house what kind of
dreams do we want to have here
how much is too much time on the
internet have these little things have a
weekly calendar meeting have a monthly
or bi-monthly
budget meeting right do these things
regularly
and then when the fight happens when the
mother-in-law calls when the
father-in-law does a thing when the when
those things show up
there's not all this pressure built up
so it just explodes
right then you can just have a regular
old dis
disagreement a passionate one if that an
argument
you can get after it yeah just yelling
and screaming
yeah so how do i feel when couples say
they never fight either living in a
fantasy world
right and they are building a pressure
valve that when it goes
it's going to be it's going to be a
volcano
right or somebody's super dishonest yeah
everything's great everything's great
and those are the people who just
disappear one weekend
right their husband goes out of town and
they get home and everything's gone
right or they're defining
fighting differently meaning you know we
don't yell and scream because that's
stupid and doesn't produce anything
we do have passion and disagreements we
do get frustrated we do take breaks we
do
i'm gonna go eat by myself tonight i'm
gonna go watch a movie by myself
i'm gonna sleep in the guest room
tonight i'm just smoldering right now
and then we will circle back and loop
back that happens um
i don't believe the couples don't have
that with some regularity
so all that to say is however you define
fighting is is the key to answering that
question
but no it is not healthy to have
somebody with which
you never disagree with who doesn't
challenge you who doesn't push you who
doesn't say
what about this let's try that you need
that person in your life to continue to
lean on you and push you towards getting
better right
all right so let's go let's take one
more call let's go to ruth in chicago
illinois
what is up ruth hi
um well we're trying to figure something
out and i've been binging your podcast
and it seemed like a better idea than
google
yes um listen you're not going to get as
good of information but it will have
more fun how about that
works for me all right so what's up um
my eldest my daughter
is 15 and she is facing a diagnosis of
schizophrenia
okay okay let's stop right there that's
a lot
right yep and by the time my family gets
to this point means you guys have
endured
a hard 15 years is that right
uh probably more like seven or eight or
nine years
um in her case no um her symptoms are
pretty new
okay so tell me about anything that has
been life-changing
um and so there's a lot to figure out
and uh
so anyway the the there's a lot to
figure out but the question that i have
for you is that
one of the things that we're wrestling
with the most is that she has expressed
to me more than once that
she would like to share this diagnosis
with her
friends with her teachers okay with our
extended family
and um that brings up a lot of fears for
myself and my husband her father okay
and we were wondering what advice you
would give us
and you know if it was your daughter
what advice would you give her about
that part of the decision
uh okay first thing i love your heart
awesome question
thank you for being bold and brave and
asking this question and
we live in a world where that that level
of bravery that you just asked
we can't do anymore because one group's
gonna say you're nuts one group's gonna
say you're discriminatory like
i appreciate your heart um so
when you say facing a diagnosis of
in a relatively out of nowhere
this thing just showed up what is
showing up
um about four months ago she came me
very upset in the early morning
and told me that she was having she was
seeing people
okay um she's having visual
hallucinations of people
okay every day and no have they done
neurological exams there's no brain
lesions or anything
correct we've pursued a lot of different
tests to try to rule out all of the
possible physical explanations
there are a couple outliers that we are
still trying to get approved by the
insurance
um but they are outliers you know we'd
have to get like a full pet scan
yeah she's had all the obvious ones
she's had all the blood work for
parasites and she's had the mri and
she's had you know all of those things
checked is she having
um is she going to war with these
people that she's seeing is it an
uncomfortable thing or is it just a
recognition that there are people there
that i
know intellectually are not there they
are not threatening
um they are unsettling because she knows
they're not
real okay okay um and so
what has when you say they're facing so
they're schizophrenia obviously for
those who don't know
you often whittle it down it's it's a
process of elimination till you land on
a place right exactly um
we're running out of landing gear okay
what is
the benefit of this diagnosis
because this is a relatively permanent
diagnosis
um i'm not entirely sure
um you know she's just completed another
round of
uh neuropsychological global evaluations
um and we're waiting on those but it
looks like
you know something in the family of
schizophrenia is pretty much our only
option
okay and regardless of the exact name
how is she doing the question is still
the same you know
what does she do with this well here's
here's why i'm getting it here's what
i'm getting at
what actually is happening um
if this is yeah if this is
has to do with like a neurological issue
if this has to do with
um like surfacing traumas if this has to
do with
several things several things that are
not schizophrenia
right that is not confirmed um
that you have this diagnosis then i
would recommend
telling people i'm really struggling i'm
um having challenges i am seeing thing
those kind of things don't bother me
here's why maybe okay maybe i rephrase
the question
okay maybe like take the label or
schizophrenia off the table
okay how do i answer the question from
her
i want to tell my friends that i see
people who aren't there
gotcha okay do i tell her that's okay
that that's safe
or do i tell her that's a bad idea
so here's the balance i want you to
strike number one
if this is schizophrenia this will be
with her for the rest of her life
and this will be something that she
navigates and negotiates and i don't
want her for a second
going to war with her own body going to
war with her own mind
right i don't want her hiding things i
don't want her trying to put
com parts of her heart and her mind in a
compartment
the more that she can own who she is oh
and her challenges
the the biggest challenge with someone
with schizophrenia is keeping them on a
treatment plan
and if you can keep people on the
treatment plan keep them taking their
meds and keep them practicing you know
hygiene and connection with their people
then there is some some successful
outcomes
right it's when people start
when they stop being stop stop being a
part of their treatment plans
and that comes from compartmentalization
that comes from hiding that comes from
withdrawal
and suddenly people are out and so part
of me says
good for her the other side of that is
if this isn't confirmed yeah i don't
want my 14 year old
just going to school and using this as a
way to connect with other people right
absolutely i mean give teach your kids
something and go well that
didn't turn out how i planned we were
intentional and deliberate and we taught
our kids
that we keep surprises but we don't keep
secrets that's right because
secrets hurt people right and she says
to me i don't i don't want to keep this
a secret
and i don't
i don't know how to meet that and say
what to do with that next
there's a difference where i would where
i would change it is um there's a
difference between a secret and
something that's private
and when it comes to medical things when
it comes to
our bodies some things are private
they're not secrets they're private
right so um if
i've got some kind of medical condition
that might be embarrassing right
um i might tell my friends hey i've got
some
medical issues man i'm not gonna be able
to go to this or that i may
i'm not going to encourage a child to
disclose everything that's going on with
their body
um because other kids can't hear that
right now talking to you i agree i i'm
afraid of what
can happen if she opens herself to this
and she's
unmoored and she's scared and you know
everything doesn't seem quite real right
now and i'm afraid of her opening
herself
up to being hurt in a new way right but
i don't want
to turn this into something that she has
to hide some sort of thing that's wrong
with her
i mean she she comes to me and she says
you know mom what if we can't figure
this out
what if they they can't figure it out
what if i'm just crazy
and one of the most terrifying things
and i've had a few interactions with
kids
over the years who are heading down this
road
and it is a it is a trajectory that's
why i thought you had dealt with it for
several years for it to emerge like this
in that way
um that my first thought is something
physical but again i
trust you and definitely trust um your
family and your doctors so
um the most terrifying part of this
pushing them pretty hard
yeah the most terrifying thing and i'll
tell you
um i'm just being honest with you as i
can okay
the most terrifying part in my
experience is walking alongside
young people in this situation is that
they can
consciously feel themselves losing their
mind
they see it they feel it happening and
it's they there's seasons when they know
there are people here or i am having
hallucinations of
or i am feeling that i am being listened
to by
that clock over there whatever the the
challenge i've experienced
and they also simultaneously know there
are
no microphones in that clock there are
no other people in this room
other than you deloney and that in and
of itself
is the scariest part i can feel myself
unwinding
and so i think as her mom your job is to
say
you will never ever be alone in this
deal
as long as i can help it and you will
never
lose us you're never going to lose love
you're never going to
lose this connection here as long as i'm
on this planet i'm plugged into my baby
girl
and what i wouldn't tell her hey that's
never going to happen because that's not
true i would say yeah this is really
scary scary for all of us
and you are not walking through this
alone and when she says things like
mom what happens if i lose my mind
that's when you respond with
that just sounds so scary doesn't it
tell me about what you're feeling
you can't promise her one thing and you
can't promise her the other thing you
can
walk you can model for her i'm listening
to these fears
right and as a parent i know how
powerless this feels
right for sure powerless
i do think it's important that she not
set herself up with her peers
she said you said she's 14 15 15 15.
yeah i would i would draw a distinction
between private and secret
right and maybe
um i'm trying to think of something
i'm trying to think of something that's
not um
i don't know if i had testicular cancer
i would tell my closest closest buddies
i would not announce that in big spaces
not because i'm embarrassed about
testicular cancer but i don't want to
have
extended conversations with people that
i'm not close to about it you know what
i mean
right and so one of those is i would
tell people i got cancer
and they'd say what kind of cancer would
be like yep and
they'd go they know exactly what i meant
because i'm grown up right and there's
people that i would talk to about it but
i wouldn't just go put that out there
because of the impact on other people
not on me
if you listen to this show enough you
know i'll just talk about anything so
i think teaching her the difference
between secret and private is one thing
the second thing is making sure she's
got people at school she can talk to
her so she knows she's not broken she's
not dirty she's not disgusting she's not
gross it is not normal
it is out of the ordinary but she is
still beautiful however she was put
together
and so making sure she's got coaches or
teachers or
guidance counselors at school that can
give her a safe space
and what i would recommend is having
somebody she can see face to face so if
you went and met with a school counselor
have you all done that
um it's very difficult they just opened
the school for people to
that aren't students um to come in so i
could physically go see her counselor
now but i haven't yet
i would write an email to the school
counselor exactly what you told me
that we've been getting testing over the
last four months this has emerged and
this is what where we're headed and we
want you to help us with some guidance
with our young one on how to navigate
this at school
i'm not comfortable with a 15 year old
owning this narrative
here's why it may go away and here's why
it may not be schizophrenia
if i'm you i would tell the doctors i
want to the
a diagnosis of schizophrenia to be a
last
thing we only do that if we have to
unless insurance says we're
not paying for the meds unless unless we
have to
um and i want to see if there's some
other ways we can work through this has
she already taken start taking
um antipsychotics are sure taking
medication
um we started with some anti-anxiety
medications
um working on that angle to see if that
was kind of feeding this
um and that didn't really help she's on
the lowest dose of an antipsychotic
right now okay and
it has helped but they're not gone okay
all right
is there any sort of behavioral
interventions
diet exercise go outside play with
people
not different than our lives were before
um
we're we're fortunate enough to live far
enough outside the city that we've got
property and
animals and she's out and getting that
vitamin d and that activity regularly so
very cool what's her interaction with
other people is she allowed to do that
um could she play with friends
can she play with kid other kids um she
is involved in
so much like i said she's she's a rock
star um
she's you know in some clubs and some
organizations
um outside of school that keep her
moving
yeah um and and and keep those
connections going but it
it's all everything's a different format
this year okay
yeah and part of me wonders man is there
some sort of environmental issue here
some sort of physical issue then the
combination of those has
set some things off that when she gets
more into a routine and gets back and
again that's me being optimistic here
so here's a bigger question
how are you and your husband dealing
with this how are you all
um my usual response is to uh
to dig in and give myself lots of
practical things to do so right now
my job is just to tell the doctors and
get as many tests as i can and have
those conversations with her when she's
scared
um i i know that from
from other crisis in my life that i will
have to circle back around and
and do some work on myself as well but
i'm i'm not there right now
you didn't answer my question though
how's your marriage
um interesting um
i don't know that i've ever heard my
husband say i'm scared
yeah in as blatant terms as he has
lately
yeah what was your response to them
me too um
he's a very practical person he can
learn how to do anything he can
if the plumbing's working he'll just fix
it and if the car needs something he'll
fix that and
if the electrode is not working he'll
fix that in addition to the two jobs
that he's working so
you know he came to me and he's like i
this is the first time i've just looked
at something
gone i have no idea what to do with this
here's what here's what you do you put
down
the solution part of this because y'all
can't solve this
okay what you can do is stay
hyper connected to one another continue
to be vulnerable and proud of you
for um inviting him into that
conversation i'm proud of him
for being a vulnerable guy living out on
acreage saying to his wife
i i don't know what to do feeling scared
is right
and what i'll tell you is i've seen
these things when student students
of mine have been on treatment plans
that they
hang in there and can go about life
are they always going to have challenges
yep they are thinking about life
and then i've seen some hard things
where kids get off their treatment plan
and things are really difficult
and so the fact that that your
daughter's got a
bulldog of a mama in there ready to go
to war on her behalf is wonderful
it's great you've got to temper that
with
putting your own oxygen mask on too
and you've got to temper that with
knowing that part of
her journey is a safe house and a safe
house starts with a
you and your husband intimately tethered
together rock solid that we're in this
for the long haul and letting your
daughters be
heard and not making any promises that
we can't uphold
and here's the thing this is just scary
and it sucks and it's awful and um
it's that lack of power it's that lack
of control right
yeah i'm sorry
and i wish i had i wish i had better
options for you better news for you
better all this stuff
um but going back to your original
question to me
is um yeah there's a difference between
privacy and secrets
and some things for 15 year olds need to
stay private they need to stay a secret
and stay private uh but she does need to
have some folks at school she can talk
to that when she does get scared when
she does get
unnerved she'll have a signal with the
teachers a signal with the guidance
counselor she'll permission his get up
and go into the
counselor's office and she'll have a
group of adults watching her while
you're not there and that will give you
some peace of mind in your heart
and hopefully the doctors can get to a
resolution relatively quickly and then
begin a
treatment plan that's going to be
hopefully short-term but more likely
long-term
and the more we can practice the more we
can get her connected with other people
and the more we can get her following
this treatment plan the more it will
become part of her rhythm and her the
rest of her life
um 15 for whatever it's worth is pretty
young
usually it's late 18 19 20 21
up to 25 and so i'm gonna keep my
fingers crossed this is something
unrelated
and that she's struggling with something
else and it's not schizophrenia and
we're gonna
just stay optimistic and um keep praying
and
keep hope alive on this one
ruth i i just can't thank you enough for
your heart let me know how those
conversations with the school go
and make sure she's got some folks there
and continue to
look at your daughter and let her know
she's beautiful she's perfect the way
she's made
this is scary and while you can't make
the
scary things go away you will be with
her right you will
be with her all right as we wrap up
today's show um
i was listening to this on the way to
work today and i thought
man what a great record what a great
record
it's off the rights of passage record i
think it was 1992
two women and two acoustic guitars
indigo girls and the song is ghost
and it goes like this there's a letter
on the desktop that i dug out of a
drawer
the last truce we ever came to from our
adolescent war
and i start to feel the fever from the
warm air through the screen
you come regular like seasons shadowing
my dreams hey poets take a note of this
one
and the mississippi is mighty but it
starts in minnesota at a place that you
could walk across
five steps down and i guess that's how
you started like a pin prick to my heart
but at this point you rush right through
me and i start to drown
and there's not enough room in this
world for my pain and signals cross and
love gets
lost in time past makes it plain of all
my demon spirits
i need you the most i'm in love with
your ghost
this is the dr john delonie show
[Music]